what can explain that
eerie unsettling feeling we sometimes
get that we've experienced a new
situation once before it might just be
the weirdest experience you'll ever have
sober but what exactly is deja vu one
thing it definitely is is common 2/3 of
us have had it with younger people
Globetrotters and film fans likely to
get it more frequently because of its
inherent weirdness
DejaVu was long thought of alongside
paranormal events like clairvoyance and
reincarnation in fact it was
parapsychologist a meal Buraq who first
named the feeling in the 1870s using the
French for already seen the focus on the
uncanny has persisted and in films like
The Matrix deja vu is a glitch in the
computer simulation so what's actually
going on the truth is no one is a
hundred percent sure but psychologists
have suggested dozens of possibilities
combining theories of memory perception
and cognition one is devided perception
may be our brains process a situation in
a quick and shallow way before we become
fully aware of it and then we get a jolt
of having seen it before
another is dual processing incoming
signals enter the temporal lobe from
both hemispheres of the brain one a
millisecond later than the other and
it's in this moment of delay that deja
vu occurs
others speculate that errors around the
hippocampus the brains librarian are to
blame the problem with studying deja vu
is that neurologists can't very well
wait around for it to happen
one solution has been to look at people
with temporal lobe damage then you find
that they get chronic deja vu another
way to study deja vu is to induce it
under lab conditions in 2012 one study
used virtual reality to immerse people
in different 3d environments some of
which were very similar in layout for
instance a doctor's waiting room and an
aquarium with furniture arranged in the
same configuration people were more
likely to report deja vu when they
encountered environments that had a
similar layout to previous forgotten
scenes suggesting it's a memory
phenomenon a 2014 study had very
different results those who took part
was shown a series of words with a
secret common theme words like beds
pillow nap dream the linking word sleep
never appeared viewers were asked to
keep note of any words beginning with s
those who took part were later asked if
any words began with S and sure enough
they said no but many also felt that
they had been shown the word sleep for
two thirds of people this confusion was
tantamount to deja vu neurologists have
used this method to scan the brain
during deja vu they found that rather
than being a memory error in the
hippocampus deja vu involved the frontal
areas of the brain responsible for
decision-making
this led some to suggest that deja vu is
a sign your brains memory checking
mechanisms are actually working well but
if you're looking for something a bit
more out there to explain deja vu try
quantum entanglement perhaps through the
mysterious affinity of subatomic
particles deja vu might actually be a
window into a parallel universe or else
obliterating time thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe and click the
bail to receive notifications for new
videos see you again soon